So, it seems we can use plus with numbers and we can
use plus with strings. What if someone tries to use plus with
a string and a number at the same time? So, suppose my
name is actually the number 9. Well, when we try and run
this, what we get is an error. Here's the error we get.
This is a little different from the syntax errors we've seen before.
This is still in the Python grammar. But it's something that doesn't
make sense. What we tried to do was concatenate a string, which is
the string My name is, and the number, which is
the integer 9, and it doesn't make sense to paste
those together. At least Python doesn't know what it means.
So this produces an error, we can't add numbers and strings
together. We can multiply strings though, this is a little
strange. And so, here I'm doing the exclamation point string
times 12, and what I get is 12 exclamation points.
This is better than having to type them all out. So
I can change, instead of doing Hello
name, exclamation point plus exclamation point, I
could do exclamation point times 3 here. And this would be the Hello Dave with
3. So if I'm very excited to say hello to myself, I could do
exclamation point times 38. And then I'll
get Hello Dave, followed by 38 exclamation points.